hey everybody welcome back to poker
Thanks today it's time to tackle
kaiserburg now the description states o
order just need to click on that the
description states that the eccentric
owner of this ski slope wants to be
prepared for a climate change I didn't
remember putting his political message
into the game interesting but it's
rather unusual but if you could work
with the steep terrain and ignore the
cold this remote location could serve as
the site for a unique theme park all
your coasters need to stay close to the
ground can you use the slopes to your
advantage and then the goals are to get
450 guests into the park have no loan
debts and have an overall park rating of
75 percent which is not going to be too
difficult so the overall idea is that
this is a ski resort which we're not
even gonna use for skiing anymore we're
just gonna turn it into a theme park
because the earth does kind of warm up
too much anyway which to be fair the ski
resorts are definitely one of the areas
where this is most notable now I already
have to say I don't want to fake this
too much I've actually already almost
finished this scenario but I'm gonna
skip that spoiler for another day let's
pretend like I'm starting a new file
here it's a bit of a weird recording
process that has gone on throughout the
making of this video I've recorded this
in Brussels and back home in the
Netherlands on my laptop entirely in
some different locations and I'm trying
to record this right now at 2:00 a.m. in
the morning before I leave tomorrow
morning to go to Austria to go skiing so
that's very topical so altogether this
video is coming together in a very very
strange sort of set of circumstances but
I'm trying to get this content out you
know trying to stay on that grind you
know you know what I mean anyway this is
this is the map so we have a simple
monorail going to the top of this hill
let's just say Mountain because this is
actually quite huge as far as
terraforming goes in Pocket X and that's
all we have so as you can see quite
simple now we're not allowed to build
above tree Heights so I think as soon as
I try to build anything too tall yep
there you go it's already in the red so
that's gonna be quite the challenge
otherwise we have some basic flat rides
not too much and some roller coasters
that are actually going to be
quite a challenge to make profitable so
not the easiest part definitely but then
again the goals for the park are pretty
easy so altogether I think it's quite
doable and let's see how I did all right
so I had one basic idea for this whole
build and that was to make this park
look like a village that you commonly
find at the valley of a ski resort
mostly actually like the ones that you
find in the US so an architectural style
that's very much inspired by European
alpine architecture but at the same time
at a much larger scale with large-scale
hotel buildings and resorts and things
like this and obviously I won't really
be building hotels exactly or anything
like this but it's kind of inspired by
the same kind of architecture imagine
something like Whistler or actually yeah
something like Whistler that could work
out very well so honestly for my
inspiration this time around I just went
to Google Images and looked up a bunch
of big ski resorts and then specifically
there are sort of town centers and what
these look like and while I'm not really
drawing inspiration from anything in
particular it's just this overall style
then I'm gonna try to emulate with this
build and I think it's pretty useful for
a number of reasons of course this whole
scenario is shaped like a ski resort so
I think Thea matically of course it just
makes most sense but also given the
restrictions of the scenario the fact
that I'm not allowed to build above
three Heights which is going to make it
very difficult to rely on rollercoasters
and the roller is is that I do build are
gonna have to hug the the slopes if you
will I'm saying quote unquote slopes I
should say actually because they're not
really slopes but there are some open
areas between the forest on the hill
that I'm planning to build my
rollercoasters on but beside from that I
I can't really build any big rides
anywhere so I really want to focus on
buildings and creating this village like
atmosphere and then just putting the
rollercoasters somewhere else up the
hill and hopefully that'll work and it's
also quite difficult to focus on flat
rides because we don't
a lot of flat rides on the scenario I
don't know for some reason this scenario
just throws a bunch of different
challenges on you and one of them is the
fact that you really have to research
quite a lot if you want to get some
decent flat rides so I'm also not
starting out with too much in that
department so while I'm building these
buildings I'm definitely gonna research
flat rides and get to that in the near
future as well I'm starting off though
with the two of me on because that is
always such a good earner and even when
I end up building lots of different
rides throughout the park I think this
ride ends up being the most lucrative
one and definitely over the course of
the whole scenario playthrough but
altogether this thing always Nets a few
hundred dollars per month it's very very
good honestly one of the best flat rides
that you can build from a gameplay
perspective and also just to look at
sometimes I just end up playing the game
without actually building something I
just look at that thing going around
it's so interesting I just love that um
hmm sorry it's late I guess my voice is
gonna start to crack a little bit anyway
if you're interested in it in real life
the tool beyond is made by ABC rights
I'm not sure if it's also caught that in
real life but it's definitely a real
ride and you can find it I believe in
China or Hong Kong one of the two
although of course the distinction is a
bit difficult there but it's also in six
likes nowadays but from what I've heard
it's much more interesting to look at
then to actually ride it's just one of
the coolest flat rides as far as the
overall design goes I think anyway um so
the buildings that I've built so far are
just these big resort like alpine
structures and so sort of fits the the
station that was already in the map a
little bit in with these buildings I
decided to add some extra frame work on
that as well honestly throughout this
whole build I'm mostly just going to
focus on building stucco walls with
wooden timber work and so it's very
similar to what I've been doing in the
last episode as well not really to
difference everything's on a slightly
larger scale and there's a bit more
detail and I'm just experimenting in a
few different ways but it's very similar
at the end
the day so nothing too spectacular
definitely something that I've done in
protect quite a few times already so I'm
trying to find as much variation as I
can here but I also have to admit to
some extent I've done a lot of this
stuff before and the really only
difference between the Alpine builds
that I've done in earlier scenarios is
just that the setting is completely
different but that aside I'm using a lot
of the same pieces and colors and things
like this
and especially for the wooden pieces
many of the buildings end up having very
similar colors so I'm a bit afraid of
making everything look trab so I do try
to have slight variation slightly
different shades of brown and things
like that for every building just to
have some differences but at the end of
the day everything is going to be a bit
similar so definitely not the most
interesting build in that sense why am I
always just I don't know and complaining
about my own bills I do really like this
scenario actually the way that it turns
out in the end even if it is quite
derivative it's very coherent and I kind
of feel like what I was going for it
wasn't too original but for what it is
it worked out quite well and I'm
honestly very happy with it especially
the layouts focusing on this one square
with this big flat right in the middle I
think it works out very well
it would realistically also work for a
ski village in real life so it's
something that I think fits the theme
but at the same time it just puts this
this one major attraction of the park on
display and I'm not even going to kid
about this honestly this is going to be
the flagship right of the park because
even though I'm gonna build some
rollercoasters later on you'll probably
find that these rollercoasters aren't
all that special and definitely aren't
going to make the thrill-seekers happy
so this is kind of you know for that for
the people who are really into theme
parks this is probably the most exciting
thing that's even in this park anyway so
yeah ride wise it's not gonna be too
great it's really focused on scenery
now I film in two sides of this big
square with just big wide buildings and
for this last site I wanted to build by
far the biggest building of this whole
complex and so I'm even raising it up a
little bit I was thinking about using
terraforming here but as the scenario is
we're not allowed to use terraforming
which makes sense because if we were
that could have just been used to you
know erase the terrain and get over the
three height restriction so it's quite
good that we are restricted in that
sense but sometimes there's just these
little things that would love to use
some terraforming for just for
decorative purposes so in this case I'm
just using a lot of path works to make
it seem like there is a hill and like I
adjusted this Harrier with some
terraforming but it's not quite there
yet anyway that is going to be the space
for a later building which is going to
be the biggest building in this whole
section but first I just wanted to work
out what the general layout of this area
would be so I had an idea of you know
what this building would be shaped like
how I would put this whole thing
together so right in front of the the
slopes the quote-unquote slopes of this
map I ended up putting some bumper cars
which I'm not sure how much I like the
placement there it does kind of close
off the slopes from this village here
which somatically doesn't really make
the most sense but at the end of the day
I couldn't really find a great way to
combine the the slopes on the hill and
the actual village because at the end of
the day it's not an actual ski resorts
and you won't see the kind of
infrastructure that connects a town with
the mountain that you'll find in ski
resorts so honestly I just figured it
would be okay to put these bumper cars
here and put some paths in later too to
connect into that area and then right in
front of that are some more foliage
based elements a little bit of gardening
I really wasn't too sure what to do with
that section so I think you're just
putting in some filler trees and rock
work and shrubbery would pretty much do
the trick it also helps to you know
provide some greenery in between the
buildings because the foliage just
always makes things look better
I think that's honestly pretty
statement to make and one that I've
definitely already made way too many
times in videos I'm also keeping the
bumper cars bit simple but I do want to
theme the queue because it helps bring
some extra architecture into this area
helps close off the square a little bit
more and make it really feel like a
village so even though this is not going
to be too intricate very similar to the
buildings that I've built so far it's
something that I think really helps out
a lot and given the fact that I'm not
putting a roof over the bumper cars
itself because well it already has a
roof and it's kind of difficult to
re-appropriate that and turn it into
something else
I always think that you know putting
some sort of building next to or around
the bumper cars is the next best
solution it would actually kind of be
cool to be able to turn off that roof I
just realized I mean at the end of the
day you do often find bumper cars in
real life with completely different roof
structures so having that sort of yeah
that possibility to mess around with the
theming yourself would actually be
really cool but then again I think this
roof could easily be covered if you
really wanted to do so and really put
some effort into it but yeah it's
honestly just the thought that I had for
a second because if you I think about
real-life bumper cars I know that
rollercoaster tycoon has always featured
bumper cars with glass roofs but from my
experience usually they don't especially
because the roof has to be used for the
electricity that the the bumper cars use
either way that's a little bit of topic
in this building on the other side I
decided to put in two flat rides to
motion simulators very lame I know I
just thought I need some rides to earn
some money as well and at this point I
was quickly running out of money so if I
didn't put like two flat rides in at the
same time I wasn't sure if I was ever
gonna make a profit on this park and at
the end of the day profit is definitely
the most important thing if I want to
keep this scenario alive lest I be
building all of the scenery for nothing
so ended up just putting two motion
simulators there I don't think it really
matters too much because I will
eventually just build a building over it
but it's it is a bit lame I agree
normally I like to stick to the rule to
not copy any rides over into the same
park because it's a bit boring
but in this case I've really didn't see
another way out of it
besides I really wanted to build a lot
of buildings but not have a lot of flat
rides in the open air so I had to make
some concessions somewhere and this is
the building where it fit the best I
think given that this building is going
to be large enough to house two flat
rides including two cue lines so hey
it's just the thing that kind of works
best now for this one before I went into
the full detailing I just ended up
adding these pillars all around it to
create the shape and already have that
detailing out of the way and only after
that ending the roofs and the walls
which kind of helps actually just to get
the pillars in the right position
usually I always get annoyed when I have
to rotate all around the building to add
the details everywhere which isn't too
bad from a gameplay perspective but I
have the same always very sort of
conscious of my recording so I try not
to move the camera around too much and
definitely don't want to zoom or rotate
too much because this could be really
disorienting on the time-lapse and with
buildings where you want to add details
on all sides this can definitely be a
bit of a challenge because I do want to
do as much as possible without moving
the camera as much so sometimes putting
in pillars and details before putting in
the walls and stuff works out because
you can at least see through them and
you don't have to rotate all around the
building also there's the idea that
building the structure of the building
before you build the actual scenery is
often quite useful to make it look a bit
better and to sort of help you guide
along where the woodwork should be but
that's something for the ski resort
episode of planets coaster that I
definitely shouldn't spoil in this video
so yeah altogether as you can see this
building is shaping out to be quite
similar to the building on the other
side with some large overhanging roofs
with Gables with some balconies
underneath them it's always quite
difficult to fit in buildings on the
four grid in park tanks because you
can't deviate from it but at the same
time I always want to have some
overhanging roofs so I find that these
sort of Gables that stick out are a
really good solution to creating the
illusion of having
overhanging roofs and large eaves all
around the building when in reality
everything's completely on the grid and
besides that I ended up adding a spire
right in the middle of the building
because I just can't do without my
spires so yeah I had to add that now
finally I'm moving on to the first
roller coaster of this build and it's it
might honestly just be the most intense
roller coaster I think in terms of stats
it actually is it's a simple junior
coaster that does a quick lift hill and
just kind of meanders around this slope
here and yeah finds its way back into
the station it's nothing too
particularly exciting but it's a lot
more unique than most unique coasters
that I've made throughout this series so
that's an improvement
I suppose although that just kind of
comes with the territory of working on
this map where you have to build below
tree height and I just have to make use
of the terraforming which is always fun
I actually had a lot of fun creating
this layout and trying to figure out
where exactly it could go because it is
quite a challenge to make this work so I
actually spent a lot of time on this
layout as well I'm not sure if this was
the four heights that I ended up going
with in the end I think at some point I
might have raised the lift or a little
bit and tried to go into another
direction because I kind of got stuck at
the location where I am right now so as
you can see just have a a turns whooping
down from the left hill after a small
pre drop into these two helixes and then
after that coming back down to the
ground but I really struggled when it
comes to getting back to this station
from this position so what I ended up
doing here is keeping this layout more
or less the same but just trying to have
this awkward break run that sits next to
the station but sort of goes parallel to
it and getting to that point just took a
lot of trial and error to get like my
location right so when it comes to
rollercoasters like this I personally
find that working on it a bit longer
just always works out because I don't
know I don't want to be stuck with the
layouts that I don't really like and
roller coasters are at the end of the
day I think still my favorite things are
building
detect just with that simple
piece-by-piece system that is so
reminiscent of rollercoaster tycoon
yet at the same time so much more
flexible and realistic for me it just
hits the balance between realism and the
sort of cartoony gameplay style coaster
builder just right and it might still
just be my favorite thing about this
game anyhow I ended up finishing the
layout just like that with a simple
helix at the end and a station flyby
although I'm not sure if it's called a
station flyby if you're flying
underneath the station usually I guess a
flyby would be if you were going above
the station but we're going through the
station building regardless so I know
the excitement points don't really work
like that in this game but I feel like
in real life and they do work in a sense
that going through a station always just
makes it a roller coaster so much cooler
all of the great coasters international
wooden coasters that fly through their
station it's just great
also tornado in Finland the intimate
inverted coaster which does a barrel
roll through the station super awesome
but I have to give a special shout-out
to laughs coaster in legendia in Poland
which is just one of the best coasters
in the world kind of underrated
I guess amongst the general public
perhaps a bit overrated among coaster
enthusiasts who just like to praise it
because it's kind of the story of the
underdog for koma finally getting good
but let coaster does this amazing
corkscrew slash zero-g roll style
elements through the station and the
station building has even been designed
to have these gables on the side which
the coaster flies through and it's just
really cool it's it's such a cool
coaster for anyone who is not familiar
with left coaster but interested in
rollercoasters I highly recommend
checking it out it's just spelled L e CH
because it's it's a really cool beast
and even though it's small and it
doesn't look like that much it's very
intense
personally I had a gray out every single
time at the bottom of the first drop so
that is that is quite something I think
that's the only coaster that I
consistently gray out on so
not sure quite like how much positive
g-force it hits and for what period of
time but it's definitely one of the most
intense coasters in terms of positive
g-forces if I'm allowed to trust my
judgment based on graying out every
single time I love it
I might actually go back there in this
summer anyway I'm getting very off-topic
at the moment
basically I've been building the station
which was a quite interesting affair
because it's very tall because the
station building itself is very tall but
then I also ended up adding another
floor on top of the on top of the track
there but also underneath the station we
also have the station fly by going
underneath which I'm not sure what to
call exactly but we also have the cue
line and the entrance path so there's a
lot to fit in underneath all of that so
it's quite a tall building with a bunch
of different layers but at the end of
the day I also think that kind of makes
it very interesting so I'm pretty happy
with the station because even though
it's very simple in terms of the pieces
that I used it is it does have a lot of
interesting interaction between the
different elements of path work and
coaster track now moving on from here I
did a bit of research in the meantime
and ended up getting this the spinning
boy so I figured might as well turn this
into a new flat ride because I really
need those guests at the end of the day
I've been saying that too much this
video anyway because at the end of the
day I don't have a lot of rides in this
park yet and it's mostly scenery so I
just had to add this thing in here and
now you might be wondering why there's
suddenly a go-kart track in the park and
I have to admit I actually did record
that section and it was quite cool
actually making the go-kart layout
especially because it's something that I
haven't done that much I think the the
orchard Acres scenario was the only one
where I actually used the go-kart track
but yeah it was actually a fun time
lapse but unfortunately when I was
recording it for some reason my idiot
face decided to record in 60fps time
lapse so I felt the whole hard drive of
my laptop with that recording file and I
had to remove it in the end to make
space for the rest of the recording of
this episode
so to give a very very quick summary I
was just basically making a go-kart
track it's not too special it doesn't
have any special elements or anything
and a pretty simple station but I think
it rounds up the park quite well and
down there we also have a viewing area
where people can look at the people who
are racing which I think in park
attacked as a game people don't really
do per se but for the layout of this
park I think it makes a it makes some
sense and you also have the rooms of the
quote unquote hotel with the observation
with the simulation right inside of it
as well so all together I think it's a
pretty cool scene I did and then I did
add some extra scenery to it at this
point but yeah basically the majority of
this I wasn't able to feature in this
video because I just had to make some
space next time I'm definitely gonna try
to remember to not have my bandicam SATs
to 60fps anymore because that was a not
the greatest thing I could do in that
sense also I've been very very I don't
know not to awake throughout the
recording of this whole thing but I have
to be very honest I'm I'm going to
Australia tomorrow so I needed to finish
this recording and get this out here so
it's kind of late and I'm kind of
falling asleep but I'm also pushing
myself to put this thing out here so
it's not really quite the quality of
commentary I though that I would
normally like to go for but I gotta
provide that content and I want to get
this out also because it's super
thematically appropriate because by the
time that this video comes out I will be
in Austria I don't know exactly what the
day will be that all just kind of
depends on what I decide to do with it
but yeah this is actually very thematic
because not only is this a ski resorts
based map but it's specifically based on
ski resorts that I will most likely go
to and when this video comes out may
actually be ads specifically and this is
an interesting background I can't
believe I'm only now just saying this is
based on Elmo which is part of the same
area as well
westendorf
Wow it's it's a giant skiing area near
kitzbühel in Austria and before a few
years ago they used to have a real line
a funicular going up to the top of the
mountain and that is what the monorail
in this park is basically inspired by
because I wanted to build a scenario
that would resemble ski resorts but of
course Park tank doesn't have gondolas
or chair lifts so I figured a monorail
might just be the next best thing
because sometimes you find these kinds
of funiculars in real life ski resorts
as well
they are quite an old thing so they are
slowly being phased out so in Alma for
instance it was replaced by a 10 person
gondola by Doppel Meier a few years ago
but it's a cool thing nonetheless and to
get back on track for a little bit I
decided to add my second coaster which
is the Alpine Coaster after the horrible
disaster of Hickory Hill in the last
episode that you guys fortunately or
unfortunately didn't get to see beyond a
quick screenshot I decided to add a
Alpine Coaster to this park because at
this point I was already making enough
profits and I couldn't really you know
care too much if this Alpine Coaster
wasn't going to run a profit besides I
needed to get more guests into the park
because that was my main challenge at
this point and even if this thing isn't
very efficient it's you know bringing in
the money I do hope that it's very good
at bringing in people into the park and
eventually it will definitely prove that
it does just that so for this scenario
actually I think it was a very good
decision to add this ride because if
this ride is going to thematically work
in any scenario
it's definitely kaiserburg in real life
you can find these on many a mountain in
Europe throughout Austria and Germany
specifically I know there are lots of
them personally I've been on a few of
them as well one in fibrin in der in
Austria and also a bunch of them in the
Black Forest in Germany I really love
these things
although to be honest they are a bit
less interesting I find then a typical
bobsled old like summer Autobahn as they
say in Germany but
and they're really cool I really like
them and it's something that I thought
is super funny
I don't know if I'll be able to see this
during the the real-time section at the
end of this video checking out the park
but something that I thought was super
funny is actually that you get these
people in the game who if you just break
the whole way down on these things and
end up you know slowing people behind
them down as well which is totally
something that happens in real life and
like my only nuisance with these
coasters is that every now and then you
get these people have a major difference
in how much how fast they want to go and
you know it's totally fine if you prefer
to go slow you know that's the that's
the fun part of these kinds of coasters
everybody has their own brake pedal and
you can always you know make it as slow
or fast as you want it to be but it's
it's kind of annoying if you want to go
down with no brakes and the person in
front of you is some of the much slower
sort of preference so it's something
that happened to me quite a few times
and it's really fun to see it happen in
the game as well I will say though in
general people go down this thing super
slowly I did test this ride and on my
test runs it went down pretty speedy but
then again when it's testing it doesn't
do any brakes and as soon as people
start riding it they do slow down
significantly which funnily enough isn't
very realistic I guess because without
somebody actively holding down the the
brake you automatically start braking so
I don't think you could even test these
without a person in them unless there's
some sort of system to you know remove
this effect on the brake because the
great thing is that you always have to
actively you know not brake and as soon
as you let go the thing just start
slowing down so that's kind of cool how
they work there they're really good fun
and anyone who hasn't been on one of
these things I greatly recommend
checking checking one of them out if you
ever have a chance they're honestly not
even as scary as they seem at first I
know they are too particularly scary to
the average coaster enthusiasts but
they're really just quite slow and much
less intense than the
and look so I think they're cool it does
all just depend on what the layouts of
the one that you're writing is like
though because some of them have some
really steep sections and some of them
are just kind of slow and meandering now
the final thing or while the final ride
that I decided to add into this park
actually no this is not the final ride
this is the second to final ride is this
bunny boy here which is always a good
one because it draws in a lot of crowds
at this point I was really just trying
to get in a bunch of final flat rides
the majority of the most important
scenery was already in here I just
needed to get more people to actually
visit the park so that I could meet the
objectives so this is another attempt to
bring the guests what they want more
thrill rides but otherwise I'm keeping
it quite simple I do want to experiment
a bit more with color schemes though
because I've noticed that on many flat
rides so far I tend to be a bit safe and
simple when it comes to the color
schemes which is kind of a shame because
there's a lot to be experimented with so
for this one I ended up picking a sort
of dark green and lights yellowish green
color combination which I think works
out alright with the foliage in this map
and then finally here's an orbiter with
a dark sort of purple color scheme
eventually not too exciting but then
again there's not too much that you can
really change about the colors of this
thing but this is actually the right
that ends up not completely being
necessary because I was already reaching
the cause of this scenario but it's a
it's a good way to finish up this part
of the park and basically make it so
that there are no dead ends anymore and
that's basically something that I wanted
to try and yeah honestly it feels like
the park is not too crammed at this
point but it definitely feels like there
was no more space for me to add anything
significance so it feels like just the
right time to end this scenario both
from a gameplay perspective and also
from a whole design of the park
perspective so without further ado let's
take a look and how the park is doing
alright so unfortunately it's raining so
it's not really the great
sense of circumstances to win this
scenario in but there you go I've
completed all goals and it's basically
all finished now if the weather can be a
little bit better I would love to show
off this park a little bit more okay I'm
just gonna fast forward all right so
after that unfortunate combination of
rain and confetti it's finally time to
take a good look at the park so here we
have this station for the roller coaster
not quite sure why I'm doing this not
entirely chronologically a bit of a
Tarantino esque walkthrough of the park
I suppose but yeah here's the roller
coaster as you can see it's quite simple
but I do like this layered sense of the
station with different parts and tracks
all kind of mingling together and
forming this interesting complex whole
let's do a quick POV of this coaster
it's actually quite smooth as far as
junior coasters go I know I keep coming
back to it I've built so many of these
throughout this whole campaign play
through but this is definitely one of my
favorites as far as the layout goes
anyway so a bunch of curves that sort of
sweep up and down one big drop in the
middle of the layout here before we
start curving back up and then we turn
around the station fly through it there
come over to this helix of path the
interaction here and into the brakes
which also serve as the block brakes
which make sure that this coaster has a
decent well capacity I should say but
then again it's something that
apparently I don't really need because I
rarely actually feel all of the trains
this thing is actually an efficiency
monster in a sense but right that's not
very efficient is the Alpina coaster
here and I barely even see anybody
riding it right now ah there we go
somebody I really hope this person
doesn't want to brake too much because I
do prefer this thing to be a bit
speedier yeah nevermind
there we go it's this he or okay that's
that's definitely what is it though I
don't know this person whatever there's
their gender is is definitely a paved
this slow type when it comes to Alpina
coasters it's too bad that there are
that many people on the right right now
because it's actually interesting to see
how it's sometimes slows down as some as
soon as if one person goes down very
slowly
I imagine this person might actually
catch up at some point in the future but
probably not but as you can see just
slowly making her way down this is
actually a really cool jump that you
could catch some air time on if you're
one of these Daredevils that goes down
these things with no brakes I think ya
know they are both kind of [ __ ] let's
be honest something that I also didn't
really talk about with but which makes
sense I think for this type of coaster
is that the lift Hill has these three
different sections where it curves
upwards because in real life they will
have a cable lifts but it's not always
attached to the track for the whole
duration of the lift hill so they have
these upward curves to make sure that
the cable stays on the track and
underneath the carts and you'll often
see it you know fly through the sky in
front of your cart as well so I know it
looks a bit strange but this is actually
with the lift Hills of Alpine coasters
in real life are shaped like as well
they're really an interesting coaster
type and definitely a lot of fun anyway
moving to some of the scenery here is
the general scene of the town the the
big main square with the crazy two of me
on in the middle of it call it a
hyperspace cube or whatever else I don't
know what's another good English name
but anyway it's a really cool flat right
love it and it's a cool centerpiece for
the town I think with her the big
building with the the simulators in it
which I'm not actually sure if anybody
even writes those yeah maybe not but it
definitely helped attract the and the
necessary amount of guests into the park
so that was good and this this very
thick tower as well I never really make
my towers this this bats if you will but
I think it works out with the thatch
work and the overall roof structure
altogether it doesn't seem too strange
and then we have the topspin here sort
of finishing off this section of the
park
of course the bumper cars here
a very interesting building actually
that I didn't talk much about for the
Gravitron which the Gravitron Xhosa kind
of reminds me of these old marshmallow
candies with that sort of red swirl and
and white swirl here but yeah it's a
it's a pretty interesting sort of
structure for a flat right building that
I haven't really tried before but I'd
love to try something similar again in
the near future because it worked out
better than I expected
and then here are the go-karts which I
didn't really showcase too much but as
you can see it uses a very simple gable
roof with the gable sticking out on
different directions here and then the
track itself just contains a bunch of s
bends and curves here and there it's
really quite simple
as far as go-karts are concerned it's
mostly benefits from the scenery around
it having lots of trees and rock work
and some basic deco items to help make
it a bit more interesting and of course
a viewing platform over here as well and
it's already raining again great and
then here's the the token flat right
that I forget to open before I run the
park great that's something I just can't
help but do no matter which scenario I'm
playing apparently anyway that is just
about it for this park so I'm gonna
leave it at that's and quit this game
and see what the next park is that I'm
gonna get with this because honestly I
actually don't know the order of the
scenarios at this point okay so for
kaiserburg we're getting the big
communications tower that's on top of
the mountain and moving into this valley
over here
what's that gonna be silica slopes oh
boy that's gonna be a good time okay
great I'm not sure if everybody knows
what silica slopes is all about but this
is honestly one of my favorite scenarios
if not my favorites out of the ones that
I worked on it's very reminiscent and
very inspired actually by a particular
roller coaster tiger in one scenario but
I will talk more about that when the
time comes for next time I might
actually try to tackle Sakura gardens
instead I'm not entirely sure it could
be either one of these two anyhow thank
you guys for watching and I hope to see
you in the next episode bye guys